bem meu nome é felipe meu tema as
plantas em extinção sem impacto no
planeta
eu escolhi sistema porque adoro padres e
preocupo muito com elas e quando estava
no segundo ano exatamente um ano de 2014
minha professora pediu para ir ao jardim
botânico
fui lá conhece mais sobre se todos de
que o brasil descobriu diversos biomas
da mata antes a 236 essa mensagem
extinção
o cerrado a sentem que é uma espécie
mensagens isso renatinho a 46 espécies
mensagem extinção e viajei pelo brasil
descobri que tem diversos biomas e que
nem que neles há pontos a mensagem sam
tem uma enorme fora mas mesmo assim após
a mensagem são um exemplo delas é o pau
brasil que sendo ameaçados de extinção
em dezembro os colonizadores em geral a
fazer tintas segmentos musicais
embarcações confusões que várias outras
coisas como design é outro ponto que
também está ameaçado de extinção que
demora 12 anos para ser coletado eu ser
cotado leva aponta morte
o bambu é outro ponto que também está
ameaçado de extinção que a chover serve
de abrigo para os passos também a canela
preta pau-rosa araucária e várias outras
coisas
agora falar daqueles fatores que
contribuem são da fora primeiro até de
menor impacto
depois fiquei de maior impacto menor
impacto são com preços de papel lápis
instrumentos musicais construções e
várias outras coisas
hoje maior pato seu combate à lavagem
estação de mim minério pecuária
queimadas construções e para outras
coisas
e minha família todos atitudes para
diminuir esse pato como reciclar reduzir
consumo de carne vermelha e reduzir o
uso de outro de utensílios de madeira ou
sem ser de garantir que reduzir o uso de
utensílios feitos de couro e várias
outras coisas
eu e minha família e amigos do meu pai
tivemos uma idéia para tirar essas
contas a mensagem extinção como a gente
implantar sistemas sa distinção e
apadrinhar elas quer dizer que vamos
cuidar dela até de nossas vidas
assim elas poderão diminuir e as pontas
mensagens são idéias não podia para não
podia parar por aí
minha idéia é distribuir sementes com um
papel dizendo os dados mais adequados
para ela
assim poderemos plantar e semear
esperança obrigado